House Democrats are preparing for a
historic vote to formally impeach
President Trump in just two days the
House Judiciary Committee released a 658
page report on the impeachment overnight
that lays out the case from both
Democrats and Republicans and a new CBS
News poll finds 42% of Americans think
that if President Trump is impeached he
should be convicted and removed from
office but an equal amount say the
Senate should not convict him or not
hold a trial at all
16% say it's too soon to say Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill for us Nancy
good morning what is next what's next is
the House Rules Committee will hold a
hearing tomorrow night to lay out all
the procedures for the full House vote
on Wednesday some Democrats still
haven't said how they plan to vote
Hawaii's Tulsi Gabbard is one of them
but Democratic leaders say they are
confident and they're already planning
ahead for the Senate trial that's to
come I think this whole thing is a crock
Senate Republicans ready to defend the
president are signaling they prefer a
speedy trial with no new witnesses I am
ready to vote on the underlying articles
but Senate Minority Leader Chuck Schumer
sent a letter to Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell last night detailing the
witnesses and timeline Senate Democrats
want to see he proposes that Chief
Justice John Roberts who will preside
over the trial issue subpoenas to for
administration officials including
acting White House chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney and former national security
adviser John Bolton who were both asked
to testify in the House impeachment
inquiry but did not appear in a
statement McConnell's office responded
that the majority leader has made it
clear that he plans to meet with leader
Schumer to discuss the contours of a
trial soon I'm gonna coordinate with the
president's lawyers McConnell and the
White House are coordinating on strategy
we wouldn't be doing our job if we
weren't working hand-in-hand with the
Senate to clear the president of this
charade this sham on Sunday Democrats
accused McConnell of violating his duty
to serve as an impartial juror
here you have the majority to the Senate
and infect the foreman of the jury
saying he's going to work hand in glove
with the defense attorney and that's a
violation of the oath that they're about
to take and it's a complete subversion
of the constitutional scheme Republicans
argued it's the house process that was
unfair I think this is the beginning of
the end for this show trial that we've
seen in the house conservative groups
see impeachment as a winning issue for
them they're targeting House Democrats
in 31 congressional districts that
President Trump won in 2016 including
New Jersey's Geoff Andrew a conservative
Democrat facing a tough reelection who's
expected to switch parties after being
wooed personally by President Trump on
Sunday five of Vann Drew's staffers
abruptly resigned in a letter they wrote
that his switch to the GOP quote does
not align with the values we brought to
this job Gail all right Nancy thank you
very much